they used to play football on this field
but there's no time for games in Benny
the city has a public health emergency
on its hands
the Ebola outbreak has swept through
this part of Congo and the communities
only treatment center is overwhelmed so
NGO MSF is going to build another one in
a week the the current treatment center
is overrun they've been adding capacity
every week they went from 40 beds to 50
to 60 and I don't think anyone really
expected that things would move this
quickly in Veni so what we're doing
right now is really trying to play
catch-up with the epidemic last month
officials said this outbreak was almost
over but their confidence was misplaced
instead it will soon rank as this
country's worst Ebola epidemic with a
multinational team now struggling to
contain it this is a really difficult
area to operate in the city is
overpopulated hosting tens of thousands
displaced by war and the local
population is weary they just don't
trust anything the government says or
does we joined a decontamination team as
they searched for a house on the city's
eastern side a woman who lived in this
outbuilding has been diagnosed with
Ebola and team members have come to
sanitize or destroy her things her
husband now worries he has it too means
a new kanako-sama corns
who some we're going to ask it to mom
my family will deliver milk and then you
can have people in Tennessee tomorrow
another group will turn up with an
experimental vaccine and the entire
neighborhood including mr. McKenzie will
be asked to take it the vaccine is
administered by special teams who track
down people who've had contact with
Ebola victims then administer the dose
it hasn't been approved by the health
authorities but early trials show it's
effective still there are many here who
have refused it imaginable works I
really do kilowatt sensitive a live axle
appearance daily service we saw that if
AC system defeat that's one reason why
this outbreak is so unpredictable some
even claim the vaccine is satanic no
really that's those people those people
they are can take Eli's candidacy the
people with the facts yeah certainly
that's quite there's another reason why
this outbreak is so difficult to control
Beni is in a war zone the Congolese army
has dug itself in on the city's
outskirts after frequent incursions by
rebel militias the head of the World
Health Organization says he's never
dealt with an epidemic so complex the
situation where we have this outbreak is
very different from previous outbreaks
even the West Africa outbreak because
there is a serious security problem here
there is armed conflict here active and
that complicates the situation the risk
is clear in a desperately unstable
environment the Ebola virus spreads and
the Bene outbreak becomes an
international epidemic John Sparkes Sky
News in the Democratic Republic of Congo